pensez y ait trouvé l'amour vraiment
cette émission pourquoi on veut trouver
partout à la sûreté est la même sur ce
plateau exactement cali canu la
transition est toute trouvée vivent
dangereusement au bachelor du post le
bachelor dubost ces trois personnes
trois prétendants oui malheureusement il
n'ya que gérard louvin qui a les mots et
jean michel maire jean luc est ce que
vous voulez participer quand même ah bah
c'est comme vous voulez alors mais
visible et je suis pas là autant de mes
camarades jean luc lemoine aussi sera là
parce que je joue mal on ne fait pas
gagner jean-luc parce que on sait qu'il
est déjà au dessus dans leur si vous
pouvez faire gagner qui vous voulez bien
entendu vous on aura une rose
on aura une rose vous aurez va secondes
pour séduire camille et on aura une rose
après que vous remettrez à celui qui
vous a le plus séduit
attention on est parti on démarre avec
thierry moreau et camille aller à table
à lévis
vingt secondes sachez que ce dîner qui
se passe les vives tensions entre ap
entrée plat dessert en même temps c'est
20 secondes fak d'astro voici ça passe
vous avez dit mais nous aimer a dit
mitchell oui ça va vous adorez télé me
rappelle ma jeunesse j'ai pas draguer de
attention voilà moi je suis marié
ils apprennent pas il après pause je
voulais vous offrir ce petit précis la
philosophie du baiser avec des textes de
ronsard bruno passant de mal à régler
très joli et puis aussi une petite
connotation un petit peu érotique et
sensuelle donc voilà j'espère que ça me
verra j'espère surtout vous trouver
l'amour et ses pairs ne trouverait pas
dans les émissions comme le bachelor
j'adore il ya des textes de ronsard tout
ça il ya métamorphose de renault de
beaux jours j'adore ce texte mercière
pour le groupe
je parle dans une nouvelle ère en régie
sur la vie d'un chat ils sont en train
de fumer il ya d'autres in et corrigera
détourner mon gars allez le deuxième
prétendant gérard louvin merci canal a
dû vous voyez tout de suite c'est la
technique à l'ancienne à la baisse voire
lassé des shadows c'est pas pour vous
c'est bon c'est bon cette très belle
j'ai une protégée pas enrayé le top de
ta part dont vous êtes très belge est
une questions vous avez une grande
famille oui est-ce que vous avez des
frères moyens rapporté pas non ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que moi je suis
un peu la voiture balai l'appui mon âge
et je vous emmener sur la route du
bonheur avec mon gps générosité présence
sécurité bon là c'était bison futé 1
allez jean luc le braz
je suis content qu'on ait ça c'est de
l'intox
je suis content qu'on ait ce moment
ensemble je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
concurrence
je suis pas te mentir j'ai pas l'humour
de thierry j'ai pas le pognon de gérard
je vais pas te faire croire que j'ai
aperçu rapide gens comme lui d'abat jour
michel mais je suis content de te
connaître et impôts a été dit un jour
donne moi ton coeur bébé ton corps j'ai
vu une femme like you et et avant de te
laisse te connaissais pas et maintenant
que je te connais ça serait difficile de
pas se connaître
vous attendez tous bien sûr le playboy
dpeba je me rends d'accueillir motard
jean michel mr aller
les scènes et synchrones ne mettez pas
le bon gars on saura sort arrêter ce
massacre suite s'il vous plaît et fait
ce qu'il veut et quand on sait ce qu'il
veut il parle déjà de très longues moi
je suis pas fou comme vous j'ai peur
d'être trop ému donc du coup j'ai pris
des notes à l'essai par l'as caniches
teckels un petit poème là en mettant un
gros vent à paul dans mon coeur
désormais tu caracol que moi tu
trouverais bien sûr bien plus beau et
moins vieux mais si tu ouvres ton coeur
je me perdre et je ne perdrai plus que
dans tes yeux pour qu'un jour peut-être
devant moi ta robe tu des zips je
m'engage aujourd'hui à remettre pour
toujours un slip
depuis cette fameuse cérémonie tu as
avec un thé pas une [ __ ] permet -
retour et sans autre chichi de t'offrir
cette jolie fougasse
à
et la brigade oui mais bon maintenant
est maintenant les gars et c'est une
fougueuse donc de chez paul donc voilà à
cause de vos conneries à cause du sexe
âge et bord citer d'autres noms
boulanger j'en connais pas la vidéo et
la mie câline bien sûr mon ami à côté de
moi
voilà qui s'appelle chez jeu cgg voilà
tout ça merci alors prenez tous vos
cadeaux venait avec moi vous allez
désigner celui qui va repartez avec la
journée
mais après la pause comme écrit propose
comme les filles tout épouse derrière
cam et camille vous allez regarder la
caméra là bas est dir est guère celui
celui que vous désignez et celui à qui
vous offrez la route s'il vous plaît
thibault de calme allégé camier je dois
pas dire acceptes tu sais trône oui si
pacy mais alors vous l'appelez vous lui
dites accepte lotus et rose et on verra
ce qui en résultera voulait une musique
de suspense
allez moi je veux bien
nathan fait une tête de suspense un
bouton avancé sait pas faire ça allait
jean-michel
les bijoux
non
merci cas mais elle a joué le jeu merci
et bravo en tout cas et camille et vous
nous avez pris et sauriez lui croyait au
parti avec un bisou leurs pratiques